zumindest in vielen bundesländern haben
wir gerade herbstferien das heißt mama
und papa kacheln mit den plagen über die
autobahn und beschließen sich scheiden
zu lassen
wer unterwegs mal pause macht tut dies
in deutschland sehr wahrscheinlich
einmal raststätte der firma tank & rast
über 90 prozent gehören denen das ist
ganz nah am monopol und das hat konkrete
folgen für uns verbraucher allein seit
2015 allein in den letzten drei jahren
hat sich der preisaufschlag für benzin
gegenüber anderen tankstellen bei denen
mehr als verdoppelt vom pinkeln war ganz
zu schweigen
wo ist der schön so ein scheiß haus papa
können wir nicht hier urlaub machen
so
doch schön wenn kinder so
begeisterungsfähig sind ja
um den witz man zu verstehen tank & rast
besitzt nur die gebäude alles andere
alles drum herum also auffahrten
parkplätze die autobahn finanziert der
steuerzahler also ich wir alle gerade
mal drei prozent vom umsatz fließen
zurück an den start
trotzdem muss ich fürs pinkeln bezahlen
ja gut ich krieg 50 cent zurück aber
sind in deren tanken mal was für 50 cent
haben sie etwas für 50 cent nein keine
ware für 50 cent ich arbeite hier nur
ein verkaufe tut mir leid
es wird auch immer alles teurer ich
meine cola für drei euro das ist doch
wahnsinn
also ich würde auch in kleinerer städte
gehen und sowas kaufen ganz ehrlich ganz
ehrlich wir kaufen nur idioten möglich
ja das passiert wenn die politik einen
de facto monopol duldet über jahre unser
bundeskartellamt hat mal ganz kurz
ermittelt und dann gesagt ja ist nicht
schön aber man kann ja von der autobahn
runter fahren dort gibt es autohöfe
leider fängt tank und rast jetzt an auch
die aufzukaufen
gehen sie mal auf die seite von denen
müssen sie wirklich mal gucken da gibt
es ein wunderbares kinderbuch über die
tank und rast erlebniswelt da steht dann
bevor es zum essen geht müssen alle zur
toilette mama sagt tim du darfst durch
diesen eingang für kleine kinder kostet
es nichts
dann gehen sie ins restaurant mama fragt
was wollt ihr denn essen die kinder
suchen sich ihr lieblingsessen aus toll
oder
wir haben die geschichte man realistisch
weitererzählt und weil mama und papa den
kindern auch ein extrem überteuerte size
kaufen haben sie danach gar kein geld
mehr
macht nichts papa arbeitet seine
schulden bei tank & rast als klo putzen
ab und mama geht natürlich auf den
fernfahrer strich
ja
radio marca
was mir gerade einfällt klo kostet 70
cent 50 cent kann ich nur wiederholen
für die teuerste cola der welt wer
kriegt denn die differenz der
raststätten pächter die 20 cent bekommen
sie denn da was kann so wird
keine antwort stattdessen ein
hilfesuchender blick zur seite
denn dort steht der mann der hier
eigentlich das sagen hat der schläger
von tank & rast ja extra zur interview
überwachung eingeflogen solche szenen
kennt man sonst nur aus erdogans türkei
seit 2005 10 gehören die einem
konsortium bestehend unter anderem aus
allianz versicherung und abu dhabi
investment das heißt jedes mal wenn
ihnen auf der autobahn in deutschland
die blase kneift fließt geld nach abu
dhabi es fakt das kann doch so nicht
weiter gehen wirklich da muss es doch
alternativen geben tierischen dran aber
keinen bock auf teure autobahn toiletten
kein problem dann hol dir jetzt die
toilette wirklich überall umsonst
winkend und mit den eigenen an stoff die
dieselabgase säubern
die auto lette und für frauen die auto
lette ultra einfach laufen lassen wunsch
barren
[Musik]
endlich meine nützliche erfindung
seit 1998 wurde das stellten wir uns
privatisiert und wenn man dabei steht
doch im privatisierungsvertrag von
damals von 1998 ganz klar hier zitat die
tank und rast ag wird regelungen
hinsichtlich einer unentgeltlichen
benutzung der sanitären anlagen
akzeptieren
das steht da und schon 2012 wurde unser
heutiger verkehrsminister damals noch
staatssekretär aber genauso schön auf
diese sanitäre schieflage hingewiesen
ich sehe nicht wie sie sagen die
verträge sind erfüllt wenn wir geld
zahlen und hier steht etwas von
unentgeltlicher benutzung das verstehe
ich nicht dass sinn von tank & rast
natürlich eigenen wirtschaftlichen
überlegungen die wir nicht zu
kommentieren haben ob ich nicht zu
kommentieren ja what happens insel
sanifair klosters in der sanifair clown
übrigens eine rückabwicklung der
raststätten privatisierung wäre sogar
rechtlich möglich das fordert aktuell
die bundestagsfraktion der linken mit
antworten wird nie passieren
ich finde es zum kotzen so wie ihr seid
mal
obwohl wir schalten jetzt mal live zur
tank & rast zentrale in bonn albrecht
humboldt ist dort chief of marketing and
human experiments warum wollt der umwelt
wie rechtfertigen sie eigentlich im
monopol ich dachte ihn so was gibt's bei
uns gesetze ja gesetze sind ja
eigentlich auch nur vorschläge hier in
niedersachsen zb da gab es mal ein
gesetz da stand drin dass gaststätten
grundsätzlich kostenlose toiletten
anbieten müssen
also was kommt als nächstes
behindertenparkplätze also wirklich
manchmal
naja jedenfalls wollte dann wirklich so
ein kleiner bürgermeister einer unserer
raststätten verbieten den pippi preis
von 50 auf 70 cent zu erhöhen
ein anruf von mir beim ministerium und
der musste den schwanz einziehen
am 21 dezember hat der betreiber unseren
bescheid bekommen und am 22 dezember
sind wir vom ministerium angerufen
worden und werden das nicht so erwartet
dass wir da in
nach unserem gefühl einer sehr raschen
und direkten weise zurückgepfiffen
werden nazis von wegen die politik macht
nichts wenn was wirklich wichtig ist
dass man dann handeln die innerhalb von
24 stunden diese dieser engel ist ja die
haben einen bürgermeister
zurückgepfiffen der sich gegen
verbraucher abzocke wert nein die haben
noch viel mehr gemacht
von riko man erfahre ich dass dann 2011
das niedersächsische gaststättengesetz
geändert wurde
anders als normale gaststätten dürfen
autobahnraststätten geld für toiletten
verlangen
und wieder hat die gerechtigkeit gesiegt
nur für uns wurde extra ein gesetz
geändert ja da haben wir quasi aus der
not eine tugend gemacht
ich verstehe das nicht in vielen ländern
kann ich alle autobahn umsonst aufs klo
warum nicht bei tank & rast gegen frage
herr welke warum dürfen in deutschland
täglich millionen menschen klein machen
oder sogar groß ohne dafür zu bezahlen
und zwar bei sich zu hause dafür sind
das gelbe gold in der kanalisation ohne
dass auch nur ein einziger investor aus
abu dhabi einen müden cent verdient so
kann es ja verdammt noch mal nicht
weitergehen
deswegen unsere neue idee sanifair home
denn du 80 über 80 millionen deutsche
haben bei sich zu hause nämlich ein klo
wissen viele gar nicht oder hier
sanifair to go ideal für die
karnevalszeit
bald ist elfter elfter es gibt noch so
viele möglichkeiten ich sag nur dann die
wurf für hunde affen oder oder warten
sie ich hätte mir gerade ein sanitär
bezahlen fürs atmen 70 cent ein euro 14
hat recht humorlos zwei jahren gut ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]